what up crew yeah get the dog go boy
just put this back on to cover up the
man wounds I get um she's up there now
those of you who've known what we've
done for a while will remember that a
long time ago we did some some audio
episodes and I don't know I didn't know
how much time we would have left exactly
the end of it anyway we didn't know how
long and I get before the cold ball to
piss hit this dish well like that is
that they're cold which is it
people pre-prepared yeah um which means
ons uh which means that in front of me I
have some classic trivia question
this is what
I mean they're from 1984 I mean again I
am gonna read out the answers all you
have to do is guess the questions are
you all ready god
really as we did this in a smaller fart
filled room in Chester a way we had a
really big career that one of the night
said he he destroyed the room so badly
we had to open the outside door to let
the math down that was about I fell off
your a bed and headboard your drum kit
our memory we start with Albert Blake
dick which blight didn't make like seven
yeah because Nixon would be seven on a
sugar sing servicing the shapeless [ __ ]
it sounds like a not it sounds like a
harder Albert Blake dick what's breaking
someone I don't know well I know what
you use it's when Gareth Thomas comes up
behind you know two people got my
reference thank you both like seven fans
in the audience not an LC uh this has
actually been corrected since the lines
of this would be Thomas Edison uh who
shaft did who out of some kind of tape
well our dick was on who named I can't
say Blake dick which I can't say that
Albert Albert was the one who named it
so we are looking for an invention and
we looked F alone oh no no we're looking
for something that it's still using an
office today photocopier chair I love
tricity Gary you're very close I'm
something a little like photo copier
that was a Xerox Corporation that was a
bit what what was an earlier version of
that typewriter carbon copying yeah
alright I'll give you the point of
mimeograph
minion Graeme mio mio sounds like
electro bad yeah I'm done with the kids
Anna hello a mimeograph machine yeah and
we're here to annoy you pre show us
that's actually fair yeah uh we move on
to 235 what yard line do you do
Shambhala chat in American football you
don't get your bollocks at an American
football no very Roger that's rugby and
that's after oh they do them don't they
you're absolutely right it is some it is
a yard line American football yeah do
one go any anything weights okay
sometimes you go to a stiff you go
that's where you kick the thingy this is
why you never know American football is
one of the few sports I sometimes watch
and I also know whatever so and yet is
it the line you kick the thingy yeah the
thing is he's right that that's what you
get for watching the Super Bowl isn't it
yes super bowel yeah helluva show yes
it's which yard line two NFL teams kick
off from and before we get letters this
is from 1984 it was moved ten years
later before we get letters said yeah
you I'd quite like that because the the
YouTube barrier to entry would be quite
a bit higher if you had to comment by
sending a letter but on the other hand I
would open my post in the morning I was
just you've got a letter owner as well
Tom lives near an embassy I think he
does have a silver platter that is
posters down private and gun for them
for you said no I just like the idea
that I'm going to open a letter and it's
just going to be a vague insult on my
person you know all in caps all in caps
obviously I would be he had YouTube
comments by post you are crap oh that
would be post with the word lull in it
yeah yeah uh your next one is hiya
lecture the answer is almost always
thatcher hi ally fastest ball speed
compared to lacrosse she absolutely
spot-on knocks out the park it turns out
how it bounces off the wall comes back
yeah uh your next one is the impossible
missions force what are the colors on a
date night wow that makes my answer even
worse Ministry of ungentlemanly warfare
no no definitely not sixty-four Newton's
the impossible missions for all right
yeah good I'm gonna collect your
magnetic send jobs but you know whatever
I know the the abbreviation for that
would be IMF um what where does the post
get misdirected if you write into the
International Monetary Fund um anyone
who has seen certain films like people
know the answer to this he's absolutely
right what is
dude
yeah what was the name of the agency so
mad at the back you just go sort of
cross out this is your next one is our
interest we're in the worst place to
store a bottle of water is when it comes
out without the cap on that's been a
good I store all my water lying down
anyway Oh
where would a York Sherman put things in
the earth endorsed yeah guys know that
you would be saying this in an accent as
well doesn't like you just dude I'm bear
in mind this is 1984 they're like
questions about certain countries Russia
yes ah it is the state-run travel agency
of the Soviet Union ah mandatory tourism
what I mean Russia travel does you I
think I can only imagine that you
basically went up there said I'd like to
go somewhere and I said no just [ __ ]
cytro is that big blinds they pull down
god no no no I would like to go under
the holiday from what I understand from
what I've read essentially you went
there and you got your week's allowance
like leave but because it's leave from
like the country in essence and you got
a week in this data at the place you
were told to at the time you were told
to be there and then you returned
Butlins then yeah but the coach will
read yeah yeah I have spent I have spent
one brief holiday in Butlins and he's
not all it's cracked up to be
and it's not cracked up to I'll tell you
what when I I had a holiday bullen's a
was brilliant but B I was just sort of a
bit worried by the barbed wire and guard
towers right on the edge I'm not joking
they were genuinely guard towers why to
stop I'm not sure if you to stop like
other people getting in or the stop was
getting how would they I don't know
oh let's go up break into violence
because nobody's absolutely what kids in
a in a small boring seaside town would
do you would absolutely go and break
into the buttons there are great slides
each of the Machine one might get you on
the way down
haha this is turning dark so let's move
on
off Butlins and South get on the side no
you got a breakaway republic of Ponting
blue coats red coats they don't don't
talk all right your last question that
baseball and bridge we are looking for
something they have in common mastered
an extra card in the box the way I play
it so so first of all that's quite
clever but no uncertainly what bat do
you use in bridge cricket and it speeds
it up
was there ever an iron baseball because
you could say both have been designed by
Brunel this wall is superior to all
others song it's also slightly too big
for everything else as well yeah no
we're looking for four terms or eight
I'll give you a point from one of the
terms that is terms of endearment in
both can have a go yeah go for rubber
absolutely spot-on it's which two games
have both a rubber under Grand Slam and
that is such a good bit of obscure
knowledge because I like despite all the
gangs that we've ended on Gary coming
out with a really obscure mint of
knowledge and absolutely nailing it
shall I save this nail then but at the
end of that it is clearly Chris that
wins so congratulations
congratulations you win an enclosure in
which underwear is forbidden run by the
star of face-off relentless no don't do
this
I've worked it out don't do this song
Gary take it Nicolas Cage
it's Nicolas Cage's Nicolas Cage
with that for the final time tonight
please give it up for Chris Joel
I've been comes home scoffs yeah
thank you good night